right the angry birds have landed at
topgolf there's a new family-friendly
game to enjoy there
all right we've got rocky theist she
loves going live from there last time is
a few months back before the pandemic
trying out their food
what's happening there today rocky you
remember that kirsten yes and i have
definitely had my share of french fries
since i've been here okay so we are live
here at topgolf because there's a new
game
that's special you guys are always
bringing new games but this partnership
is cool because well i can
well it is awesome we've always had some
really fun games but this one
is really good for people who are not so
good at golf right very much like me
so this one really helps with that and
everyone can play this game
and it's just really inviting and really
fun okay so let's talk about how it
works because
i think for me the most satisfying part
is when the castle comes down so explain
that to everybody
right actually so you're trying to hit
anywhere on the castle
okay knock it down so you want to knock
out the legs or something like that so
that whole castle crashes down all right
we want to get all those pigs down
okay so we have waiting we have waiting
on the t right now are you ready
you ready yeah you got your strategy
yeah okay let's see let's see it
let's see what you got let's see what
you got i'm gonna come over
okay yeah i might need you to go get
make something crash
can we can you do that can you do that
okay
and i want you guys to also know that
there is a special dance
to this right kim hey kim kim there's a
special dance to the angry birds right
there is a special day okay
and we can look that up on youtube i
think we have video of it so when you
after you hit when you come to topgolf
you have to do the video
you have to oh okay dad just hit
now do we let's see let's see if it goes
down
[Applause]
there goes there it goes
[Music]
okay see that is the satisfying part to
all of this because
when you hit the ball you want the
castle to come down
right right i want to knock down all the
pigs you want to pick up all the pigs
so okay so this family has been coming
to talk about they're actually from
chicago
but this is her first time just waiting
loves waiting you actually love angry
birds right yeah yeah i love it
yes you have something cool yeah okay
steve you guys have to bring your family
but this is something you can do
social distance safe here at topgolf
coming up we're gonna hit the dance for
you
all right thank you rocky i've got to
try the angry birds version because the
last time i played two weeks ago i got
16 points total for the game
so low i need to be playing angry birds
all right rocky we'll check back with
you in a